I I wanted him to build he he takes it
off because she's like how can I trust
you and and then he takes the the the
helmet off and I'm like that says
everything wrong about Chief right
because we it's she cooking go ahead
goad it's built on a legacy of trusting
this character by not seeing him as a
human being his human face it's it's
having built that trust over years and
years of playing his games um with him
as the digital character and it has
everything to do with what's in his
heart and not what the the men you know
like the menacing sort of like thing
that we look at from the outside if
anything we come to trust the menacing
thing that come that that we see on the
outside so in order for her to not trust
that rips away everything that's that
pillow's built